今日はスティープアップんです
僕は言葉の勉強大好き
今アラームを分シャードと子を同時に勉強しています
8海洋の言葉を知ってるんですよ
しかし日本でも世界的にも一番
まあ
勉強されている言語言葉は英語なんですよ
しかし英語であろうがアラゴであろうが中国語日本語スペイン語なんだろうが一番
友好的な勉強方法は
木ひなが日だから今日は英語の聞き流しについて話ししたいと思います
まず第一
英語のあるいは他の言葉の木々なが強いが
その勉強の一つの
活動として
非常にあの
利点があるんですよまず非常にやりやすい
いつでもできます
今 amp さんの mp3プレーヤーとか非常に便利がそういう設備がありますから
マヤさ
浅川んんその準備する時に作る時に
あるバナーなどを聞きながら
その汗バーを作るんですよ
あるいはさらいをする時に
ど65を聞きます
だからあるいは運動する時に
場所なんか電車の中運転しながらそういうあの聞く機会が毎日
かなりあるんですよ多分
別に無理しなくても1時間くらいのそういう聞き流しの時間があります
だから奇異な日英語の危機や的な菓子は非常にやりやすい
だからそれは一つ
もう一つはですねその機器なら塩
友好的になるためには
あの
聞き聞くものがな洋画
わからないと分からないといいんですよ全部わからなくても
ただ何も分からないその使われている単語は知らない
全然わかないそういうような英語の聞き流しはあまり意味がないんですそれはまあ
雑起こりなら音楽聴いてもいいんですよ
だから
今日の言葉英語なら英語を聞くときに
まあ
わからなくても後そのテキスト
読める
テキストを読んでその知らない単語を調べて
でもう一度聞くあるいは
60%ぐらいの内容がわかると
だからあるいは大部分わかるかあるいは
わからなくても調べる方法がある
それが姫
ように大切
であの
僕自身の場合はですね新しい
言葉を勉強するときに割と簡単なものを何十回も繰り返して着るわけですよ
引いたり読んだりその知らない単語を調べたりまた読んだりまた聞いたりするんですよ
だけでも処理は砕氷の3ヶ月間6月間の間だけなんですよ
で皆さん多分その
ああああああ
その段階も
終わってるわけですよ
ある程度英語についての知識ある程度の単語を強引持ってるわけですよ
聞く能力を持っていますだから次の段階はそんなに繰り返して繰り返してはないという
ことを繰り返して気分じゃなくて
新しいもの新しいものしかし
この新しいもののその聞く内容の
また適してもある定期つあれば
平井単語を調べて前もう一度聞く
しかしもう一度聞くときにそれでも分からない
それは当然そうでそれが当然
何か調べたからじゃあすぐその単語が
あの覚えられるということはないわけです
ただ続く引かない続かなければならない
でもう一つはですね
あの聞き流し
その
じっと座ってですね者の集中して
聞き流しというのはあまりあの新春できません
僕の経験そうするとだんだんと私が
周囲できなくなる
矛盾的かもしれないけども他の仕事をやりながら時々はその集中力はその菊の no
アラブなら号ですねある程度
集中しない
時もあるけれどもそれのほうが
続けられるわけですよただじっと座って聴く
寄付は借りたいそういうようなやり方ではだんだんと疲れますそれは必要はないです
それよりもうーんバスの中
辞典電車の中が車の中
サララー油をやりながらそういうような他の行動もやりながら聞き流し
それが効果的だし a
そしてまあ
いやりやすいわけですねだからまず
やりやすいそしてある程度
知らない単語を調べる調べられる
あのー
経研
がないと束感に聞き流しているあまり効果的じゃないです
もう一つできればその
まぁ最初の段階は9簡単なものを繰り返してくるか行けと
しかしそれはだいたい皆さんそういうその段階も覚えてますから
今度じゃあできるだけ自分にとって面白いないよ面白い内容のものを聞きなさい
そしてできれば
公営の好きな人のないを聞きなさいというのはこのなヨガすぎかどうかこの人のこう会
がスキーがどうかそういう感情的なものもかなり影響します
その日その c
理解力とそして記憶力がそういう感情的な部分によって彼らに影響されます
だからスキルものそして
すぐわからなくても
徐々にわかるようにその可能性があるようなものを聞きなさい
だ何がスキーかそれは
一つ一人の人の話か二人の人の会話母へ
テレビバンドがー番組化へ
ネットフリックスの映画化それは数
いろんな可能性がありますけれども
好きなものを
この
理解できる可能性のあるものを
声の好きな人醤油ようなものを楽しんできく
全部わからなくてもいいしかし
聞いたものできるだけまた読んで知らない単語を調べて
倍にをてフレーズも平部てまあうちのリンクのシステムで単語とフレーズを保存します
プレイずも必要なんですよねそれであのだんだんと
聞いて聴いていつまでたっても分からないというのは意味ないわけですね
例えばテレビ番組見て
何回も見ても分からないとそれは意味ないんですね
僕の場合は登録棒の場合はですね nh スイーツで登録の映画あってそれのサブ対局
がですね
あの家の臨機のレッスンとして導入するんですよ
そしてこのあの会話を勉強します
勉強しまー相違することによって少しずつ
実際の映画の会話を
ああああああ
分かるようには徐々になりますいっぺんにじゃなくて徐々に徐々に
だから
そんなその日進歩がね非常に高早いもんじゃないんですよ
業所に徐々にその聞く能力が
だんだん頭良くなってくるんですよ
だけどもそれをそういうふうになるためにはやはり
聞いたものは誰が単に雑音じゃなくて
聞いたものをある程度その理解できるようにはなり得るような事情だから適性がある
そしてできれば好きなものそういうものをですね
続けて続けて聞き流し
すれば
聞く能力がだんだん上がってくる
そして聞く理解オフですねそれが
全部の他のその英語の
その能力会話する能力の基本なんですよね
全部周りの人が言っていることおわかれば少しずつ自分の発言力もあの上達します
まあ今日はこういうふうにちょっとこう
英語の木々のや死についての
私の他の言葉を勉強したその経験からの
まあ自分の意見を伸ばしたかったんですそれじゃあ今日はそこで
の前や頭じゃ
boo
た